what's up everyone we are back at
blockchain for social justice we are now
sitting down with ferrous or Weis how
you did thanks for coming on the show
man
no thanks for having me appreciate it
alright and we are gonna talk about
digital town awesome let's do a chief
investigator of digital found instigator
she's a instigator yes and that will
make sense in a second actually let's do
it chief instigator oh yeah okay so
basically you know digital time itself
what we do is we help people search
connect and then transact directly with
local merchants and one another all in
an effort to keep more money in local
economies
then we leverage blockchain smart
contracts to share ownership of the city
portals directly with citizens so it's
basically shared ownership for shared
community six to six success on a global
scale yes so this is interesting because
it almost seems as though we're becoming
more reliant on the major conglomerates
that deliver us what we need really fast
and it's a little bit more difficult to
for us to find the mom pause around us
yeah so actually that's where the
instigator part comes in yeah it goes
well you're kind of referencing is kind
of known as the extraction economy all
right so these internet these extractive
internet platforms they have brands
associated with them like whether that
be Amazon Cooper or BB you know you name
it over time you know it all starts out
like day one it's all good you know you
have a service you get a service like
uber you want to go from point A to
point B right but over time there's a
tipping point where the utility for the
the driver for example goes down and the
experience for people like me and you
either stays the same or increases
significantly right and this exists
across all the different platforms right
it all comes down to how they take money
in right so when you have growth capital
comes in that growth capital is for the
express intent right a creating
shareholder value which typically comes
at the expense of human prosperity right
there's nothing illegal about what
they're doing but if I you know if we
have a hundred startups right here right
and I give a million dollars to each
startup typically with this growth
capital the expectation is that 99 will
fail but at least one will have to be
100 X thousand x right so that's
actually right down the road while you
see like Twitter for example Twitter had
a wonderful wonderful business right or
has one right it
people communicate it was the defining
moment of Arab Spring for example right
but every time they had their quarterly
report Wall Street just absolutely
desecrates them right because even
though they produce let's say five
hundred million dollars in revenue it's
not it's not enough for all the growth
capital that they took in there so I
have to find ways to extract more value
and more money from its users so you
know whatever the case each vertical has
its own dominant player that basically
has the master switched to our lives and
what has happened is they've managed to
consolidate value in the form of money
but also data which they can then resell
to the highest bidder
so it's this so there's nothing so it's
basically the sharing economy it was
this really like amazing promise right
it's gonna redefine how we work when in
reality it accelerated an existing
bittle business model where we just more
rapidly sold our time and managed to
basically work more for less hmm okay so
the extraction economy is the way that
you're calling it that's so interesting
so rather than Amazon maybe figuring out
how to empower the hundreds of thousands
of small business owners that exist
across the world or across the earth or
across even there's the us list yeah
that rather it was how to how does
Amazon deliver their goods to the
individual within 30 minutes via drone
that kind of thing yeah the the essence
rather than the other way now what's the
now if Amazon becomes like a benign
benevolent entity then it's almost like
okay that's fine as long as I guess the
hundred thousand small business owners
still have some sort of work and some
sort of purpose some sort of meaning
that they can find that isn't it okay
then if Amazon does that it then what is
the significance of these super
tight-knit digital towns yeah so
basically let's just take a hardware
store for example just everyday you know
you something broke at your home you
need to go get a hammer or something
right you look up in a hardware store on
Google let's say right you'll find the
hardware store right Joe's heart we're
sure it's hardware store whatever it is
in your
or you have some lovely book store in
your town you'll find the book store
search for the product you'll find the
product on Amazon you'll find it on
target you'll find out a Home Depot go
by there on some big player versus that
of the local merchants it's so true and
what what's the significance of that the
significance of that is let's say you
buy let's say it's a book example right
let's say you buy you know for books for
100 USD right your local bookstore has
those books right but it's actually just
not convenient enough for you to procure
those books from that bookstore although
it's a stone's throw away from you right
so for the same hundred dollars Amazon
takes around 22% so that what that means
is that 22 dollars or $100 that could
have gone into your community now goes
to Amazon right and that 88 so 100 minus
the 22%
I think it's distributed to wherever
that book may have come from maybe it's
a a the Alerian Tulsa Oklahoma you know
whatever right but same thing is
applicable for if I buy it through the
bookstore then they keep 22 bucks and
the other even better 78 goes to it goes
much more far reaching that so when you
keep money locally you improve the
velocity of money right that's the key
okay but velocity of money so what
happen to be in your community so let's
say just 10 people decide to just enact
and what I just proposed right it's
$1000 right would you say within a mile
of us there's probably opportunity for
people looking for a thousand dollars
worth of stuff Yeah right
but the reason there's no opportunity
for them because there's not enough
money in the system to meet that
opportunity right so that's why I like
for an Amazon for example every I think
it's like 10 million in revenue retail
that's produced within a town through
local business creates I think 48 jobs
every 10 million on Amazon within that
community creates 4 right so because the
money is being consolidated and that
money is being transferred into share
prices which we're all part of rights
people you own a mutual funds we're all
part of it so the main the crux of this
is how capitalism just works it's not a
crime it's just how capitalism works you
take in growth capital need to produce
100x and you find some ways extract
value to meet that hundred X and convert
that meaning into share price that's
just that exists across any verdict
so the whole idea and we're blotching
can be you know paramount is in a
decentralized format right you can have
an uber but you would own the Hoover
right so it's it's not just it turns
from a cloud hosted cloud hosted
solution that's funded by growth capital
to achieve to extract value to you
become part of a cooperative movement
where you are not selling your time to
the product you were selling your value
right that's the key it's selling time
for selling value so in value versus
selling time and this isn't some
far-fetched you know crazy thing we
actually started out like this right so
like after the Crusades there in bazaars
right people came back from the Crusades
they had they they were exposed to all
different types of cultures and cool
stuff right and they basically took one
from peasant to middle class by trading
their value right
they had market monies right so like you
made wine I had choose you know we made
it work we circulated through the bazaar
bazaars used to be [ __ ] cool they
could they still could be and that's
what we're talking about it right so
we're trying to get back to that sense
of coolest and that's just cool it works
for everybody people created value right
so but what happened was every time we
even today every time we create managed
to create value between us we inherently
take away value from someone up top
right so in the Bazaar time when we
created value between one another
we got significantly Richard whatever
stir Kratz got relatively poor right so
this is why how central currencies came
about how corporations were formed so
literally overnight people we went from
trading our value to your insert a
certain vertical house in a certain
vertical where I had to actually then
sell my time because kings established
corporations and we had to funnel
everything through them right so
Bachchan's a you know if we can get see
it manifest in the way it's intended it
could be so instrumental to how
community cuz you know you know it also
happened back then people saw a future
right we weren't waiting on our cities
or the federal government or whatever to
you know to get money to do things right
we believed in what we were doing so
much because recruiting so much value
when we see this
going and we invest in our city that's
why you see like so many churches have
they got Belt town square so they got
built right all these things that we now
look at his you know archaic
you know monuments were it was actually
a symbolism of people believing in
brighter futures with other communities
right okay so there's a for every how
much money of twenty million dollars so
just as an example like yes what was the
money yes every ten million every time
so for every ten million dollars spent
within the local community forty eight
jobs are created exactly and with every
ten million dollars spent by and Mazhar
to am let's say that is how jobs are
created because you have fulfillment
centers you like it and it's a just a
you know that's a kind of reign of the
parade on Amazon it's like but this is
really good example but there's also
another part of this that the point
that's crucial which is that when you
look at the bazaar example that people
were exchanging value between each other
and that was taking away from a
centralized entity and such as an
aristocrat what happens you just imagine
these people never really had to make
money right yeah we was exchanging
whatever they produced for those of
their Idol but the aristocrats like it's
quite futile right so they basically sat
around for a very long a long period of
time not really have to worry about it
so all of a sudden someone threatened
their way of accumulating wealth that
became a problem there being a problem
yeah so so now the the essence of
continuing to exchange value between one
another has kind of been put to the side
by the simplicity and the ease of
accessing those resources that we need
via a conglomerate so a couple things
happen there right so like let's just
take over for example right we you get
an uber right I'll give you an example I
was in a lift actually yesterday great
guy his name is Rami right he just moved
here from Egypt stellar dude he this guy
missed his flight
Sacramento so he drove a guy literally
from Sacramento to San Francisco Airport
Sarah Airport Airport that ride was 120
USD Robbie took home 68 USD right so
that that Delta how how's that possible
that's what that's what that's what the
rate was that's no longer like 20% and
even 30 so basically it's 50% oh just a
different feature of extraction right
there is surge pricing that we're all
familiar with right these are just ways
because basically there's predictive
analytics early can't take that much
money it's the it's the algorithm
economy right so like even let's say for
example I say my wife and I we go to
work every day right and let's say I
take an uber every day right I take a
Hoover share all right cool right they
all know that that is my pattern totally
right my wife doesn't right so knowing
that it's my pattern they will charge me
more so if you--if I literally had my
wife just booked the same uber though
she'll get charged less because they
don't know her as a pattern yet right so
these are all just features to extract
more to again convert that into share
price right so actually the point was
about the exchanging value between each
other versus with the conglomerate yes
so so with like the Amazons of the world
of what they're not they're just doing a
more advanced form of something had
already existed right there no
difference right it's just highly
digital ties and much faster right so as
it's literally the only difference and
what happens is as they all start out
the money that we give them every time
you book a ride or book a product right
and the dough is into two main areas
right either marketing at first it goes
into marketing because the more that
they can acquire more the supply chain
the more influence they can have over it
right and then once they have enough of
a supply chain then they invest it into
technologies to streamline everything
operationally right you know so
everything becomes increasingly harder
to get a waiver they have our loyalty
right so like in the smart city space
this is what I'm championing to cities
all around the world that for too long
cities have advocated the online economy
to players that not only you can you
know they have no incentive to reinvest
that consolidation of wealth and value
back into the community
create it right so I've been literally
going around the world so this is
probably the instigator part I know it's
the first question and we went to
something else but the instigator part
is the coolest part of the job because
what I found was that no matter what
color you are how you speak what you
look like you're all in we're all
impacted by this extraction economy in a
very real way but we're very
disconnected from one another in terms
of experiencing it and as we experience
it you know in our communities we were
that we see homelessness or lack of
affordable housing or you know whatever
the the visual pain is we tend not to
attach it to what these platforms have
done and the wealth that they've
extracted and the communities that
reduce our resilience to such things
right so this extraction economy is
actually the underpinning of a lot of
the and this is why I talk to a lot of
foundations that are focused on you know
certain things right
it's the underpinning of the challenges
that we see and the wedding gap between
the haves and have-nots San Francisco
you know being a prime example you know
it's tough to look at you know a lot
yeah we talk a lot about the hundred km
you're engineers on the same streets as
the dying homeless people and we also
talk a lot about the class-based
speciation that could be occurring due
to exacerbation of wealth and equality
right now because not just commerce it's
also culture people tend not to talk
about that over time right because the
incentive model is that the platform's
are stronger the more disconnected we
are with one another right that means in
turn we to turn we turn our dependence
and loyalty to that to them and rather
than on each other on each other so you
know that's why actually I love
traveling to Europe I love going to
Italy in Portugal because you can just
sit there and look people still get
together right that's how we used to hug
it out right we used to get together
talk about our problems we used to talk
about in coordination with our local
governments that we elected into onto
power that's how it worked right but now
where things are so into your point
where things are so easy and convenient
we're just
it's a habit-forming experience so
basically what digital town is trying to
do is make local habit-forming
experience because you know our bet is
that people's human nature is to support
the local community and support one
another
however it needs to be at a price point
inconvenience level where they can
actually act on it right and that takes
buy-in from a few actors what does that
require if I can get the hammer
delivered to me via drone in 30 minutes
how would I get to a hardware store and
back and pay the same amount for that
hammer yeah so this is where blotching
comes into you know quite handy right so
we kind of look at this ecosystem is
okay what company does this what company
does that how's it gonna get to me right
sometimes it's all under one banner just
Amazon and they work with a bunch of
people there's no reason let's say you
try to get this hammer right from the
hardware store so you're searching for a
hammer right you basically the front
page of Google is like bleach front
property okay but like the real world
not everyone can afford beachfront
property that's why you see Home Depot's
over Joe's hardware store in my mock
example I thought that Joe doesn't want
to be seen that Joe is priced out of
being seen right so what if you had a
model where you can't be seen first just
because you have more money and then as
you search for a hammer let's say you
live in San Francisco I'm not sure for
you on the domain let's say you live in
Austin because I know we own that domain
Austin dot city because that's our
organizing framework so we own over
23,000 dot city domains right so it's an
organizing framework for navigating city
services well
so Austin that city national debt City
Tokyo ton city 50 cities around the
world have their own domain so we were
told them that London dot Miami 2000
more in the application process all
looking to create a more intuitive
smarter web where people can more easily
directly navigate to these things right
yeah so in this example if you search
for a hammer instead of seeing like Home
Depot first Amazon second target second
you would see Joe's hardware store and
his inventory right there because you're
searching based on proximity to you and
you're searching in your city and you're
searching for a specific product that
maybe jours hardware store has or maybe
Alfredo has afraid it may have us ever
afraid of the via the camera person here
so I'm sorry maybe part of team yeah so
maybe I'll find it was like five blocks
away and he's trying to sell a hammer
right so he would also be seen over
Amazon's of the world and so forth right
not to say the Amazons don't have a
product to sell but if you are presented
with the option literally on the same
page where you can direct your
transaction
at a similar price this actually work
out what I would go to Austin dot city
and conduct a search of their first item
you conduct a search Jo's hardware store
we show up that hammer with activity to
me it's a couple blocks away hopefully
yeah I can take ten minutes to walk
right now that it's existing yet but
we're finding more partners and local
partnerships as we have users on the
platform to me yeah because you actually
don't need a service you do there might
be a kid 18 years old that's trying to
make you know a couple bucks that could
deliver it for you right okay and we
need trust and how's the house the price
of the hammer the same price as Amazon
so so that's another thing so the price
of it the price of the hammer would if
you can negate some of the logistic
factors that these local businesses are
encountered with if you extract their
engineers right if you deduct that from
the equation it actually ends up being
quite consistent with the pricing that
you see right but they have to account
for a lot more things where amazon has
economies of scale right so our local in
a local network right the the cost
actually ends up I can't I can't
probably can't go product my product
across the global inventory but it would
be much more closer and then also more
convenient given that its local right so
you can add more convenience to justify
maybe the slightly higher cost okay
maybe yeah Nabby okay but I still simple
be lower something that like yeah
because you know these like for example
if you go it's not even I'm an extra
dollar two dollars and you actually knew
that you were supporting your local
economy then people could buy that in
buying to that as well and that's the
other thing I know they're actually
earning on it so this is why oh it's my
earning on it as well that's a good
that's a good way to look at it is
you're contributing to the local economy
which then contributes to you that then
the small business around you can
decrease their prices more they can get
more product lines they can get faster
deliveries to you you're the chief
instigator now this is this is good
you've been teaching me I like it so
week what we call it a city sherry so
city shares are basically it's a brand
name for smart contract right it's just
the brand that we give for a smart
contract so let's say I lived in Austin
I would be Ferris not Austin that City
that'd be my permanent digital address
on a wallet I host my my digital address
I saw my permanent digital identity
where I crew my reputation based on
civic behavior which also basically gets
tethered with different local deals
based on my civic behavior and also over
16 fiat currencies and multiple crypto
is coming within the wallet where
peer-to-peer it's free brick-and-mortar
it's free online as you stretch to that
hammer there'll be a small fee across
verticals right but then that fee
whatever it is gets shared with the
community so yourself and your other
city share owners within the community
so what you have are self sustaining
cities that are economically resilient
cooperating with all the other ones so
it doesn't matter that you maybe don't
want to take the time to know your
counterpart in Jakarta Indonesia that's
experiencing the same exact thing you
are but now you're inherently connected
with one another
on a platform that is unified but
federated so the difference between us
and let's say like an uber uber is
unified but it's centralized mm-hmm
digital town by design as a design
principle is unified federated so the
owner operators and community leaders
that we bring on board and evangelist
that we've liberated federated means
each note each city is his own entity
right that is just connected with other
ones right looks like a note on a
decentralized network yeah exactly so
Austin that city is a node on the
network Nashville that city yeah that's
it you have your own domain because you
live in Austin yes so but if you live if
you move to New York you get a new
domain yeah you could sell you basically
sell your old domain get a new domain
because your city so sell your City
Sheriff's so okay all right so you've
accumulated city shares by by being a
resident resident of your city and let's
say you're using local yeah and you
accrue with your with your wallet they
filled with Fiat and crypto currencies
you accrue more city shares every time
you purchase things so you have you have
the option of accruing more city shares
but each citizen so in every city it's
ten times the population so if you have
a million people it's a finite number so
that would be ten million citizens
generally seizures so each per citizen
gets ten shares yes right now they and
they have to register with like a
government ID yeah so there's different
Atta stations and things like that that
over time that
security layers right but as a we grow
so we have basically technology that
enables us to basically identification
match right so there's different like
technology partnerships that we've
created like life ID is an identity
partner that we have we work with other
vendors that are basically have been far
along on this identity journey then then
we have right so you have to sell your
shares when you move out of the city
because it doesn't make sense yeah
exactly
so there's a market place forced sell
yeah so you put your city shares on the
market so there's a market place to do
this you can't keep Austin City shares
when you move to Tokyo no yeah okay yeah
okay and then but you're entitled to
Tokyo shares when you go when you go
there yeah yeah and so then there there
has to be some way for you if there were
only ten million shares created for a
million people then and if there's
populations growing now there's 1.7
million people then how do you increase
yeah so we work off the reason so we
basically aggregate the most recent
population data and the closer
relationships we have the local
governments the better of you can
actually quantify that number and we
just simply have to adjust okay so we're
only as good as the data that we're fed
yeah yeah okay cool so this is this has
been a good lesson in how we can build
together a stronger social fabric within
our communities via technologies like
blockchain and cryptocurrencies and
community building and just different
ways of looking at the way that we
structure political and economic systems
you were teaching me a bit about HQ too
as well which was really interesting it
was like and we're Amazon's building
their next HQ and well you know
initially I was like is it did this is a
Denver or Austin because I thought those
are the two places they were talking
about it but then you were like actually
what's really interesting about it is
that all the cities that applied for HQ
to that didn't that that Amazon turned
down Amazon told them what they didn't
have in their infrastructure to make it
actually a viable place for them to move
to and so then those cities turned
around and were like crap like what are
all these things that we don't do yet
like let's go and do these things that I
have in order for us to actually be able
to become a next level next generation
city that's ready for this stuff I
thought that was really interesting on
ties together with all your teachers
yeah for sure for sure because the whole
point is to like
a tremendous amount of smart people
coming out with a tremendous amount of
decentralized technology right but if we
can't come together and figure out how
to basically embed this decentralized
technology when they do decentralize
work structure you're basically gonna
have sharing economy 2.0 and the power
curve will be far too great for us to
overcome like honestly it'll be just far
too powerful right so this is what I
keep on basically championing and you
know people will just listen to who has
the strongest voice so right now Amazon
has a very powerful voice and a lot of
influence because why because they've
accumulated so much power have
accumulated power through wealth and
data right so when they you know when
the only cities kind of applying for
Amazon HD to you know they basically it
was very secretive one be only people
really involved with the city and real
estate developers
no really city participation right or
from a Civic standpoint and then
basically they made proposals where you
know they basically gave up so much in
terms of like incentives like will offer
you more and you know will give you this
and you know some kids say he's even
want to change their name right out of I
don't know how many applied that like
many did you know many lost right
there's only probably like two to five
that are still left in the running right
so they went to all the different ones
that were left and saying you know like
you said this is why you didn't win
because you're not Amazon ready so how
these cities interpret this is like okay
we need to be like this right okay this
is how we're gonna survive the future
and I think that the point is not to try
to basically work towards the future
they say you want the point is to figure
out what kind of future you want you
want for your people and work backwards
right so I think that we've kind of
fallen victim to this theory that we
need to like we open Wired magazine and
Fast Company and we see Zuckerberg and
musk and well we're screwed unless they
we let them Shepherd us into the future
a future they want we need drones we
need this we need that when in reality I
think to a certain extent these cities
need to kind of look at their people
like okay what kind of future do we want
to create together how are we gonna kind
of reharden us the level of connection
we once had while still adopting digital
tools to be efficient at it right and
work backwards from there right now I
think it's very yeah this power player
is saying they're totally about-face
changing it because in reality these
cities don't all have to be a Silicon
Valley right it's equally important for
that those global leaders to be
propelling whatever they want to build
how whatever future they want to build
because they're very inspirational and
building it in usually fairly benevolent
ways but also for the communities to
still be having conversation about what
they want to see what they want to build
how they want to do that kind of at the
same time and then interestingly enough
all of a sudden if an economy was
starting to stay really hyper local and
hyper community oriented one could
actually see a community become like a
next-generation City I'm a local economy
there that is really strong like there's
a couple of these shops that do a bunch
of different things and then a couple
shops do these different things and
people only access those shops they rate
really great delivery speeds and yeah
and that further stimulates the economy
I mean that that is a very interesting
ideal vision for like a Gentoo point Oh
City that is not having to be dictated
by the major conglomerates downwards
yeah because these cities all have each
city has a social fabric that makes them
special right and that's why it's just a
social organism that makes them special
right so if you're good at like Detroit
with cars obviously you know the Moines
Iowa like just be good at what you're
good at and then feed into a system
where that kind of that kind of goodness
can then translate into human prosperity
right versus okay if we don't do this
quick change to become this like new
tech hub right because inevitably
everyone's going to try race to be a
tech hub there's always gonna be someone
who has more developers in you people
have more money than you people that
have more something than you right
you're all trying to chase the same
thing but if you have certain companies
that own the are dominant in these
vertical spaces that's actually what
they need they need you all racing to
the at the end outcome they're looking
to achieve right because already in the
driver's seat yeah so it's just
something to be wary of and you know
something that I'm you know you know on
this you know on this video and you know
around the world advocating for this
seems pretty important for social
justice of all just because of the
ability for a community to really
leapfrog in terms of its rather than
having a dependency on a
at that us that even a low SES community
leveraging these local community
processes could leapfrog and become that
city 2.0 faster I have a couple quick
questions that I want to ask you you're
touching on this a little bit it's kind
of the principle of that although the
bottom of the SES and the world is
slowly coming up the top is being
exacerbated by exponential technology
much faster the rising much faster yeah
what do you think about that so I think
a couple things I think every time you
have like an emerging technology it
usually reaches the places that need it
most last and why is that whenever
there's an emerging technology
corporations typically see that as a new
product suite to monetize right and
typically they have assets and they go
where their customers are right so these
are major hubs right it's all one
equation amount of business development
dollars new product you know it's a P&L
statement basically right yeah so I
think that you see these emerging
technologies reach developing countries
last because the perspective buyer for
them as dictated by the the
organizations that shuttle them into
institutions are more incentivized to
stick with where they know and where
they have assets right and I think
that's just a minute it's a matter of if
you know no matter what the technology
is if it's fed through a corporate
corporate code and kirpa corporate
construct it will operate as such right
what Apple's in EFI but oranges in it
people bananas in it it just becomes
fruit that goes into the goes into the
system right how does the corporate
client look at the new technology and
think about it as both the suite of tech
for for passing along to the highest SES
but also to the lowest SES at the same
time so yeah I think in this my personal
opinion I think that you know obviously
like Luigi's watching as an example cuz
prominent example there's certain
aspects of blockchain that are very
valuable to you know large corporations
in terms of how they sell stuff and
they're like the immutable nature of
data for example it's huge right how
they can offer that now to their whole
supply chains
but I think when they think about it
right they need to see they see it as a
journey right they map it all out this
is development this is sales this is you
know there's multiple departments in
this and I think they think about it
okay we can be global with this but to
be global to prove it out you need to
start where you know you can probably
prospect where you find most your sales
right so they actually need the early
early adopters which usually hailing
massive urban centers that were
accustomed to first to basically fund
initiatives that get it out right so it
becomes really kind of a second tier but
probably part of the plan I would say
because it you know because the people
that work within these organizations are
wonderful people that want to do you
know global good but they work within a
construct that incentivizes certain
behaviors for certain purposes at
certain times so it's just something to
be wary of so like a lot of my work with
like the you know Nations is you know
literally for that purpose where it's to
make sure that you know these type you
know like for example it's funny when
you know we're talking about like
emerging technologies and the new thing
we forget how we felt about the old
things when they were first knew right
when they'd be internet or sharing
economy like internet was supposed to
start out as a way to like transfer
knowledge between government and
academia right and then private sector
basically said this is a really
interesting social organism
let's try that out right and then you
have the Internet what it is today which
basically pulls on every of our
heartstrings to buy stuff right and then
used to but yet you still have and then
your sharing economy was just same thing
but you have people working longer for
less and massive massive massive amounts
of humanity has never seen anything
never experienced any of these things
right so I think that's all just a
byproduct of who shuttles these
technologies into our life what their
incentive is where they get money from
and what they're tasked to do with that
money
in most cases a corporation almost all
cases a corporation is tasked with
taking you money believing in a certain
product suite getting that product into
the market using those profits to expand
to scale that solution and typically
that happens in places that are more
willing to buy they have more capital
which does not include maximize
shareholder exactly so it's just it's
just this is not a crude low-ses yeah
because they can't afford the products
usually she's watching doesn't walking
doesn't eliminate capitalism
all right it's a it's a technology layer
that immense it yeah yeah boss you know
immense capitalism okay couple quick
speed rounds do you think we're alone in
the cosmos that a typical question you
have alone in the cosmos no I don't I
think I think I think a lot of people
that you've had on this podcast are
sorry on this uh on this video would
probably say no as well because I think
that you find that there's a lot of
people that may not be as readily known
as some others in the world that are
championing some other ideals and
ideologies but there's many of us out
there right so I think we're actually I
think we have a pretty huge community do
you think we're in a simulation funny
enough I think we are in a place where
we are trying to make sense of a
simulation and make it more prosperous
for everybody so there's nothing wrong
with being within a simulation we just
need a simulation that creates more win
wins for everybody involved and we're
all trying to figure out okay what's the
best way to do that digital town doing
its part and many others around the
world
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world when two people that
have no reason to like each other I have
a predisposition towards one another can
get together and humanity takes over and
they see the common good within each
other beautifully said thanks let's find
those cosmic brothers and sisters let's
do it yeah and thanks for what you're
building with digital town thanks for
teaching us about it today thanks for
listening it's everybody I think I think
it's a way of seeing the world from a
from more of a you know people are
saying less tribalism less tribalism but
at the same time less tribalism doesn't
actually always mean less community and
so we can have more community within
this tribe and not have it be a bad
thing and still of these tribes engage
and interact fairly with each other but
focusing on a community first and
increasing kind of the the efficacy the
efficiency the speed the the love the
care the
economics across a community can
actually potentially be better than
having it all be dictated from a
top-down perspective so I just find that
so fascinating it's great to have
learned that from you and have shared it
today let's see we'll have Lincoln bio
for digital towns thanks everyone for
tuning in if you guys had a good time
definitely give your comment below we'd
love to hear from you we would love for
if you subscribed and joined us if you
guys found this content useful not only
share with other people don't just
consume but go create so make a video
about it write about it do your thing
tell to people go tell to people about
they'll tell to people let's go do that
also join us on patreon so we continue
doing great things like coming out to
the vouching for social justice
conference and continue highlighting
really smart people around the world
thank you very much for tuning in much
love
you